new in theaters this weekend a dogs way
home replicas and the upside what will
you see this is your weekend ticket a
dogs way home by this way to theaters
this weekend this modern homeward bound
story follows Bella a super freaking
cute dog in her journey to reconnect
with her owner Lucas after getting lost
squirrel squirrel squirrel maybe she
makes it home maybe she befriends a
mountain lion
I don't know this movie is for you if
you like dogs cute dogs make you cry or
your favorite American Idol judges Randy
Jackson yeah dog also out this weekend
replicas Wow have I ever wanted to clone
my family nope
have you ever wanted to clone Keanu's
family yup and that's what they do in
this science fiction thriller the great
Keanu plays a neuroscientist who has
been developing cloning and brain
mapping technologies you're coming on
[Music]
then wrongfully uses them to bring his
family back to life after a tragic car
accident this movie is for you if you
love keanu movies you enjoy sci-fi
medical dramas or you've been waiting
for the next great cloning movie since
Austin Powers I shall call him mini-me
finally out this weekend the upside
Kevin Hart and Bryan Cranston team up in
this comedy-drama remake of the 2011
French film inspired by a true story
Philip a paralyzed billionaire played by
Bryan Cranston hires del an unemployed
convict played by Kevin Hart as his
assistant this movies for you if you
like Kevin heartwarming drama DS moving
odd couple stories or anything with Tim
Watley from Seinfeld that is your
weekend ticket what will you see check
back next week for M night's third
installment in the unbreakable series
[Music]